this is me getting ready for time 150
favorite daughter Kirby's here already
yeah this is something getting ready
we're ready Cinderella back pretty
yellow I know but I was thinking cuz I
wore yellow on the cover you don't wanna
wear you all right I don't think I would
that's Oprah okay okay no that was Oprah
calling to say have fun tonight
[Music]
mom you're so good let's go mom Martin
Dana Marc Bouwer just made this
yesterday yesterday I know it love love
the colors pop choose-your-own-adventure
kind of thing Thank You Marc Bouwer
in one day I've been trying to describe
this it's one of those things where
you're absolutely surprised and shocked
and you can't believe it's such a great
honor but then it's also the same time
it's like of course like there's no one
better for it I'm sorry what were you
saying I was distracted by this
incredible cover right here how
fantastic is this so so proud I can't
actually wait to get there
I've gotten to this event for at least
ten years and have always always been a
looky-loo in the room so it's very
exciting to be in the room and be one of
the people on my list I think that's
that really is it was it wasn't even a
dream
even have that's what makes it so
exciting
[Music]
[Music]